[Music]
hey i'm christian i'm an outdoor
adventure photographer living on the
road full time for the past two years
i think we can all agree 2020 has been a
pretty weird one
and after spending two months off the
road in an airbnb during the covet stay
at home orders
i was unsure of what to do next rent for
another month
or hit the road i decided to try the
road and here's what it's been like so
far
[Music]
all right so i was staying in an airbnb
during the whole
explosion of covid it just became really
hard to live on the road
so i stayed in airbnb for a month in
florence oregon
and then for another month in portland
oregon i have now been living on the
road since
may 30th it has been challenging like i
don't want to sugarcoat it
uh some of the places that i would
normally park overnight have been closed
so had to get creative about where to
sleep
and um that has mostly meant forest
roads national forest
and so when it comes to showers i've
actually gotten really lucky
uh as i've traveled throughout
washington it'll move into phase two
which means the campground's open and so
i can shower and that's
really inexpensive it's like a dollar
fifty for
12 minute shower i'm at my first
campground
since uh everything closed
and today is the first day bathrooms are
finally open
and showers
showers are up and running this is the
first campground shower
and actually first public shower i've
had since february i do still have a gym
membership
which is super annoying cause i've been
paying for it since february and i
haven't been able to use it
and now the gyms are open but the
showers are still closed and who knows
when those will open
so my only way to shower right now is
campgrounds a friend's house once and
uh oh solar shower my friend picked up a
solar shower from amazon for like thirty
dollars
and we experimented with that and it
totally works it's kind of a game
changer
the only thing is you have to be like
kind of out in the middle of nowhere
unless you have a privacy curtain
um otherwise it's just awkward you don't
want to like
take a shower in your swimsuit in a
walmart parking lot you know
now that we're moving into warmer months
um it's hiking season
summer months you could take a dip in a
lake i'm staying by lake right now
so that's an option um
it's just way more feasible during this
time of year to be out
adventuring and to not have to rely on
city so much
researching locations where i can go
base
and have some privacy access to water
potentially a shower decent internet so
i can hot spot
i can still work in the van so i've
still just been editing and sharing and
writing
if things continue to spike and get
worse um
things close back down i will get an
airbnb again
um
the other thing that's kind of holding
me back is just it is hiking season
and washington has such a short window
to get outside and
and catch some of these trails that it's
really tempting to just
run off into the woods and live there
for like the next
two two and a half months
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so this is bae's first boat ride i'm
headed across the puget sound
over to uh port townsend and yeah
i got the front row view check it out
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm thinking for the next topic um
maybe safety on the road or like just
safety tips or
potentially overnight parking we'll see
i don't know you guys had some really
great questions and topics i'm gonna
comb through those
and get something up soon i hope you
guys are staying safe
and well and i'll catch up with you soon